from cointelegraph fear of angry people
drove bankmen freed to open withdrawals
for bahamians the former FTX CEO has
explained why the exchange only reopened
withdrawals for Bahamian citizens
shortly before filing bankruptcy
basically said the reason he quote the
reason I did it was was critical to The
Exchange being able to have a future
because that's where I am right now and
you do not want to be in a country with
a lot of angry people in it and do not
want your company to be incorporated in
a country with a lot of angry people in
it this this is crazy wow dude this
guy's got to be a patsy you know he's so
out of his depth here there are people
that think that he was like it was a
front a front machine to funnel money in
Ukraine in a better way yeah than to
have a tweaker that's like in his 20s
you know it's like hey let's put him in
front of everything let's let's make him
the Fall Guy here and I I think there's
also a lot of mystery about where a lot
of his money came from because the
company just kind of came out of nowhere
and then they got promoted by everyone
especially in the corporate media a lot
of people are speculating that uh and
this is what I speculated I think like
two weeks ago on my own members area
specifically that the intelligence
agencies took money probably maybe even
from the whole Epstein Saga and just
funneled it into this larger psyop which
some people are saying could be a false
flag in order to bring in more
regulations and control of
cryptocurrencies and Bitcoin so if they
were people were investing money in FTX
FTX was giving it to Alameda Alameda was
donating it that's a way for someone to
technically donate the money but
funneling it through an exchange and
then pretending like that in partnership
with the Ukrainian bank so what FTX was
yes and the world economic Forum here's
what we don't know so but the gist of
the story is FTX takes in a bunch of
money loans it to Alameda Alameda makes
Investments with it who did they invest
with the the chain of the the the the
the the chain of currency doesn't stop
right there so I have to wonder if
whatever was really going on there's a
third party out there that got away with
everything put it put it this way a
billion dollars goes in FDA let's let me
let me stop let's let's set separate
them for legal purpose legal purposes a
billion dollars goes to a company X
company X loans 500 million to to
company y company y then invests a
million uh 10 million dollars in 50
companies
one of those companies is her good
friend who says don't worry when it all
blows over I got your back and now that
companies I said oh we just invested in
this technology we have nothing to do
with anything and that's their
Investments written down to zero sorry
oh geez it's gone and no one's asking
questions about where the money where
the money actually went beyond that it's
like Alameda okay where else did it go
uh well a lot of it got hacked and and
went off the network yeah yeah and when
you say you gotta so they think it was
an Insider but the day the news broke uh
all of a sudden there's a hack in the
network all the money goes to zero and
all these people's accounts and 300
million or 400 million just leaves the
web leaves the network no one knows
where according to the news I like it
says in the article it's like he was hot
on the hackers Trail it's like oh yeah
yeah just before it happened it's um I
don't know exactly who it was because
they shut off all access to systems when
I was halfway through exploring it I've
narrowed it down to eight people I don't
know which one it was but I have a
pretty decent sense he says sounds like
an Insider like if someone has access to
the security systems of the network and
um and then now Sam is saying that he
has a hundred thousand dollars left in
his bank account which to me indicates
he's got money that's not in his bank
account otherwise he would have said to
his name right yeah he put in like he
it's in a shoe box under his mattress
well they had crypto wallets with I mean
I don't want to start making they spent
hundreds of millions of dollars on real
estate not you know so so so they have a
lot of money in assets as well it sounds
like Jurassic Park you know yeah the
dude gets mad and then takes the the
eggs but then the whole park collapses
it's like oh no instead of times it's a
bunch of tweaking 26 year old crypto
nerds that are just doing unspeakable
things to each other eating birds and
who knows is that what they were doing
well that's what dinosaurs do I don't
know I think dinosaurs were Birds yeah
we have feathers right here they were
vegan yes that's the worst the news of
Allah Sam Beckman freed was vegan oh
that explains it I thought you meant
dinosaurs I was like wait a minute no
Sam penguin you got a problem with
vegans no don't get me started B
deficiency one of the things was like
the drugs he was taking like that M Sam
drug apparently his like it if you're
eating a lot of uh like meat it is uh it
has like interactions that could cause
you to die and seriously that's that's
why the guy like more plates more dates
and a whole breakdown on the drugs he
was taking what's it called M Sam uh M
Sam how many drugs was he on I don't
know the actual number you know but but
what what what did the video say what
else was uh in that video like was there
was there like ssris was this like
psychotics was there uppers downers what
we're talking there's mainly uppers and
things that like the the drug he was
taking referring to is called M Sam and
it's a drug that basically tricks your
dopamine system to like enjoy doing
boring Behavior boring tasks it makes
you like it or enjoy it so like
weaponized Adderall
yeah yeah I guess you could say
something like that I don't make sense
his uh his girlfriend Caroline Ellison
who was the CEO of Alameda was saying
that she has less I believe I've heard
this this is all secondhand uh or third
hand or whatever but that she has no
respect for people that won't take drugs
when they work because they just aren't
up they're nice I saw that she said
something about amphetamines yes like
people don't see the world the same way
or something like that crazy just what a
drug adult way to talk it makes you
appreciate how dumb a lot of normal
non-medicated people are wow and and
like if you find out how many people are
medicated how many people are just
popping lateral you'd be shocked I mean
it's all around us like even I won't say
you know who but there are some guests
here that were just like on it and
I mean look look at uh what Jordan
Peterson he was on a whole bunch of
drugs recommending a whole bunch of
drugs and then we saw how that kind of
story played out for for everyone and I
think he's he's not the same person I
think he's a different person I think
he's been damaged by big Pharma uh
something that he's been recommending
for people throughout his entire career
that he became a victim of now which I
hope he sees as a Redemption Arc and and
helps spread the knowledge and
information so more people don't get
hurt like he did and Michaela's been
pissed lately I saw a video she's just
oh something's been going on she's
outraged about what Jordan has been
going what he went through and and I
don't know I don't know if there's new
new evidence or news about it but I
heard her talking about it it's a crazy
time man yeah you know we need I want
you to Imagine This
I want you to imagine you walk in your
kitchen in the morning there's a fresh
pot of coffee there's some bacon on a
plate and some pancakes there's a nice
family they're sitting down for a
wholesome breakfast dad's reading the
newspaper just this calm Serene image of
this like photograph of the the American
Golden Age because now our culture is
fractured everybody hates each other for
every other reason maybe social media is
the problem but I just think about that
that's what I was saying about you know
Trump's speech when he was announcing he
was running make America great again
come back to the point where we care
about our families we felt secure in our
homes and we cared about our communities
because right now we don't feel safe
people in New York I mean are getting
pushed in front of trains like crazy San
Francisco is going to put explosives on
robots everybody's screaming at each
other and hate each other for every
other reason and it's just like man
it's all it's all just like yeah I went
back to Ohio uh last weekend with to
hang out with my family at my parents
house it's really refreshing and I I sit
on the back porch and I'm looking out at
the cemetery beyond our backyard and
thinking like in my whole life I never
was worried that someone was going to
come up here with a gun and shoot me in
my parents back porch and I'll get these
waves of that now it's just like because
it's disgusting maybe it's social media
maybe it's the the high radiation coming
off these screens I don't know there's a
there's a video out of New York
there's a cop just walking down the
street and a guy walks up to him and
just execute something so yeah I saw
that too it's crazy yeah so we got to
figure something out you know this this
story about like ah man
I don't know how you restore
accountability
people should be armed okay well yes
well we have a broken system that that
is built on breaking people like people
are destroyed people are you know
medicating themselves drugging
themselves where they don't even
consciously exist in our human EX in our
in our human life so I I think you know
the problem is not just with diet but
with mental health physical health
spiritual health I think all of it is at
an all-time low and there's a lot of
seething very powerful people sucking
off of that and built a system that they
Empower themselves because of that
suffering and that and and this is why I
think a lot of the suffering is
deliberate and I think they because it's
profitable and I and how else can you
argue it because people medicated happy
and consuming that's yes that's all
short-term dopamine pleasures of things
that don't actually matter and don't
don't mean nothing planned obsolescence
just consumer capitalism where they want
you to buy something that falls apart
they want you to stay depressed so that
your constantly and outside of yourself
for a solution yeah
you've got the TV or the drug or the
sugar or the the shirt or the like go on
these videos these uh authoritarian
utopian World Views that some people
have
what they don't understand is that if
you have a unified culture you don't
need an iron fist if people are working
towards common goals and common
interests if they if they believe and
respect similar things then you don't
need to go and lock someone to force
them China wouldn't need to do the
things they're doing the problem is
what for whatever happened whatever
whatever it is everywhere the cohesion
is being is breaking down it's breaking
apart the glue that holds societies
together is is dissolving one of the
things yea said when he came on the show
a few days ago was before the show was
like what do I how do I win a
presidential election I wasn't in the
room you guys were talking about it and
you were like I don't know about I like
ballot Harvard well at first I said
something like I'm not the guy for that
and then he said you ignored my question
and then I was like ballad harvesting so
but there you go what I really think we
need is a is a is a shared Vision a
belief in in reality like we need
something to live for to believe in and
that's like space elevators and graphene
like we need to excite people about the
future that we can all come together and
believe in and then you're not going to
be worthy your neighbor's coming over to
steal your chicken you know because we
both have a shared future
so you have the fake version of it like
North Korea where no one really feels
like they're working together they're
being forced to and they hate it but
they do have some kind of uh cultural
cohesion but at the barrel of a gun I
feel like the United States uh if you go
back a while uh if you go back a long
time people people assume that we had it
like when I say like oh you're in the
kitchen and there's breakfast and
everything but there was always some
kind of conflict it's just worse now for
whatever reason and I'm not saying it's
going to get worse I'm actually feeling
like with Elon buying Twitter we could
be moving towards something better and
I'll say this it may be the cohesion is
there but the the narrative is that it's
not for example right Elon did this poll
about reinstating Donald Trump and then
it was like what 52 to 48 yeah and he
said it was interesting to see the Bots
attack then he does another poll should
I reinstate and Grant amnesty and then
at 72 percent now hold on there a minute
how is it that you have this major swing
in opinion it could it be that all the
leftists left because he brought Trump
back or could it be that Bots were more
manipulating public opinion to make it
seem like everyone supported the bunk
and then as soon as and then Elon did
that Trump poll as a test yeah caught
the Bots found their IPs removed them
did another poll as a test cleaned it up
yeah he actually replied to like someone
saying that and then like I I forgot
exactly the reply but like uh
essentially to your point that like that
was a honey honey pot to find the bot
um and the thing is like you you said
the narrative isn't there so to your
point too about the poll the poll for
free speech seventy percent of 72
percent of users support uh reinstating
accounts but there's this narrative out
there for advertisers that they're
scared
um to advertise on the platform because
of hate and disinformation so it isn't
the people that are afraid of all of
this stuff and freedom of speech because
user growth is going up people are using
the platform more and signing up more so
that should excite advertisers it's the
media and everyone else who are trying
to derail this whole thing trying to
drive the narrative but they're losing
they're clearly losing the narrative
um and again they have not reckoned with
the force like Elon before it's been fun
yeah you know yeah everything's been
going on on Twitter has been exciting
it's one this is like one of the best we
is I gotta say like despite all the
weird stuff what what y'all need to
understand is as crazy as Monday was
this is like one of the best weeks that
I think we hear like we've ever had just
across the board for one yeah we had
Thanksgiving you know I hope everybody
got to have a good time then we have
this ridiculous show that's all crazy
everybody's losing it but uh watching
the stuff with Elon election
interference we're listening to Twitter
files I'm like man it's been a good week
how are you enjoying being on on Twitter
how has been the experience of being in
Twitter in jail for so long changed you
and how is this new Twitter affecting
you it's it's just like a like a
stimulation overload I'd describe it
because so I was actually out
celebrating like I mean I was out at my
brother's band actually
um when Donald Trump got reinstated so
um right after I was having a bunch of
the House Freedom caucus members like um
texting me saying that they're replying
to Elon telling them to reinstate myself
um 20 minutes later I was reinstated
um after those tweets were sent so it
was like an hour after Trump was
reinstated as the first account after
Trump to be reinstated
um and so like all of that at once
hitting me and then like a couple Days
Later Elon replying to me and it's just
been like absolutely insane and hard to
process it when you came back on Twitter
did you have like how how long ago were
you suspended like two and a half years
it was April 2020. did you have
notifications and like messages from
back then I have a screen so I have a
screenshot uh or like a screen record of
my phone was like I could not use it
because of the amount of notifications
um and I also got this welcome back
Banner from Twitter it was super I'm
like this is a new Twitter that I'm
experiencing but my phone was unusable
for like phone calls and I was trying to
shut like the notifications off so I can
use it but I'm getting texts calls
Charlie Kirk shouted me out right away
Benny shouted me out Jack like all of
these people were shouting me out so I
was gaining I gained so I got suspended
with 85 000 followers
um I now have like 200k so I gained like
almost double what I had in one night so
it was like melting my phone you said
you didn't know what caused it but what
was the ban like what was a situation
around when the yeah so originally so I
posted this meme that they had so Joe
Biden's campaign put up this thing where
you'd post your picture and say uh say
Alex stands with uh Joe Biden it would
be you next to the Joe Biden logo so I
turned it into a meme and I said Xi
Jinping stands with Joe Biden
um so Mike cernovich quoted it back then
and he said uh watch the media spin this
into like manipulated media because that
was a popular thing at the time Dan
scavino had just got hit with like a
video that was out of context supposedly
um so like at 20 minutes after that my
account was suspended so like I put two
and two together I'm like I just posted
this I just saw like his you know
um hypothesis of what it could be a
violation
um and I assumed that was it so they
came out and said that was not the
reason
um and that it was for platform
manipulation and spam without going into
further details and you still have no
details yes so um I would do like the
regular appeals process and I'd get back
different details and like I was saying
earlier so on the day I was reinstated I
actually got one back that said I was in
violation of hateful conduct and
targeted harassment which I've never
engaged in
um so they would just spit back these
random reasons uh and originally Twitter
they said we'll show you the piece of
content that you like violated and which
rule it violated like back in 2015 when
there were it was one sheet of rules and
not a whole page of links
um so yeah I don't know the exact
violation they have refused to tell me
it's funny back when it happened so a
friend at the White House reached out to
Twitter apparently trying to get answers
and a friend at the FCC also did they
said the quote from the guy at the FCC
is the White House already reached out
on this and they're pushing back uh
they're adamant that they're you're not
going to be left back on the platform
higher ups are that was from the VP of
comms at the time at the FCC
um at uh Twitter VP of comms to the guy
at the FCC and then now what are you
doing with your newfound uh Fame and and
well enjoying I've been
I've been enjoying I mean it's only been
I think like
I think it's like nine days now I mean
this this week's been absolutely insane
so it's hard hard to control like the
days and everything but you know it's
been insane what advice do you have for
people that have experienced what you
experienced
um so I've been actually trying to help
get people re-platformed I know it's
it's all at once right now with everyone
being Mass amnesty and everything I've
actually helped I believe get a few
people back on Sven Hernandez and
Marjorie Taylor green so I was
encouraging people because this is the
way I got reinstated is replying to
elon's recent tweets with like a hashtag
bring them back and then also like the
exact username like a lot of the
mistakes people are making is like bring
back XYZ and they're like just putting
their name Elon Musk doesn't know who
those people are people at Twitter don't
know who those people are you have to
tag their username so reply to Elon Musk
or you know people in his Circle
um to get the attention but I think
there's probably going to be more
guidance next week because well this
week they're going to be out like blue
verified and everything so their focus
is on that but there's going to be more
guidance as to like what smaller
accounts need to be uh if they have to
reapply for
um an appeal or how to actually get it
back but right now I think that's the
best way is replying I need to point
something out for uh everybody listening
YouTube was having problems earlier
today it was down for for some people
and people are noticing that the frame
rate dropped to like five seconds five
frames per second super slow and we're
talking about the CIA
that's happened before like but this is
what I want to point out there have been
instances where Luke like Luke went more
than one local go off on say like the
CIA and then people watching will see
the video just freeze and like the
loading thing and then it comes back and
Luke's not talking he's talking we're
talking about something else oh my God
there's been a bunch of stuff like that
that has happened before and maybe it's
just nonsense
but uh you know I'm I'm seeing in our
live monitor
something obviously happening yeah
people are actually talking about it our
our tech people are on it I can actually
see
something it doesn't look like it's on
our end but I'm not entirely sure well
the views also dropped off there was
about like four no it's been on the
first night it's been going crazy it was
at like 53 then it dropped down to like
four and I'm like well this is no like
40 000. YouTube's busted let's put it
that way thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time